what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and today i will be
spirit diving into the absolutely
massive developments in the black clover
story including the epic conclusion to a
major battle and the apparent reveal of
the real final villain of this current
arc and maybe even the entire story
everyone is talking about the intense
fight to the death between yuno and
xenon and i will talk about it too but
the real question is who is the villain
that comes after xenon and the dark
triad and that is what i am really
looking forward to talking about so be
sure to stay tuned until the very end of
the video if you enjoy our black lover
content and you want us to keep it going
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to anime out
pro or maybe you watch our videos but
you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you have to follow
the steps of subscribing hitting the
bell and then selecting that option that
says all if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the events of the previous
chapter implied that yuno with his new
star magic was steadily gaining control
of the fight against xenon although
xenon certainly wasn't ready to give up
this chapter announces that the fight
between yunna and xenon is about to
reach its climax and that does appear to
be the case
unless a new twist in the next chapter
changes things once again the intense
clash between xenon and yuno continues
and we see both of them using both of
their magic attributes in a desperate
attempt to get the upper hand on the
other guy yuno uses his floating stars
to create a star magic whip and then he
goes full indiana jones on xenon while
also still wielding spirit of zephyr at
the same time xenon responds by
combining bone and spatial magic to
summon a magical sword called dyn's leaf
in our world dyn's leaf is a legendary
sword from norse mythology that must
cause a man's death every time it is
used so that is an ominous indication
that someone might be dying here
although this is black clover so you
know i'm never gonna say that anyone's
gonna actually die until we 100 see it
happen using this insanely overpowered
sword xenon is able to not only cut
through yuno's star magic whip but he's
even able to slice through the floating
stars that juno had been using since
juno seems to need time to restore the
broken stars xenon's destruction of
these stars is a major loss for juno and
xenon seems to be getting the upper hand
once again xenon then thinks back to the
moment he decided to join his siblings
in their plot to take over the spade
kingdom his eldest brother the fourth
zograda sibling is clearly playing the
key role in all of this and he says to
xenon that the weak die easily that is
simply the harsh reality of the world
and it is impossible to protect all of
these weak and helpless people according
to the brother it is better to destroy
all of these weak people at once and
then to be reborn in undying bodies the
fourth sibling whose face is
deliberately scratched out to hide his
identity from us says that they the
zograda siblings can use their devil
magic to remake mankind they can create
a spate kingdom that knows true peace a
kingdom full of happy citizens who are
no longer afraid of death and this
vision of a happy and peaceful spade
kingdom seems to be what xenon is really
fighting for he seems to really believe
that everything that he is doing is at
the end of the day for the benefit of
the spade kingdom but hold on a minute
this little flashback poses so many huge
questions all at once first up if the
fourth sibling is the mastermind of this
entire plan then why are the rulers of
the spade kingdom known as the dark
triad why isn't the actual ringleader of
all of this playing any part in ruling
the spade kingdom is he already dead or
is it because he's actually doing
something else something even more
important from behind the scenes i mean
if he was already dead then what would
be the point of tabatha deliberately
scratching out his face if he was some
character we barely know and someone who
has already died there would be no
reason to conceal his face and xenon
would certainly know what his own
brother looks like so this whole
scratching out of the face thing was
done specifically because tabata doesn't
want us the readers to know what the
fourth sogratis sibling looks like but
why
the only good reason that i can think of
is that the fourth so grata sibling is
actually someone we've already met
before and tabitha doesn't want us to
realize who it is just yet but if we met
him already then who is he did he maybe
infiltrate the clover kingdom or another
kingdom in order to further advance his
plans i kind of always thought that
damnatio kira looked a lot like a
zugrada's sibling but i don't think his
age matches up since he's supposed to be
only 28 unless of course he's concealing
his true age with magic some people even
think that the fourth zograda sibling
could actually be the wizard king julius
novacrono himself which would be
absolutely insane by the way but that is
a massive topic on its own so i will
actually talk more about the julius
theory at the end of the video
definitely stay tuned for that aside
from the identity of the fourth zograda
sibling we also have the huge question
of what he meant when he said that he
wants to remake mankind by destroying
everyone who is weak and then having
them be reborn into undying bodies is he
planning to turn the citizens of the
spade kingdom into some sort of zombies
or maybe into some other immortal
creature like devils is he trying to
open the tree of clifford so that
everyone in the space kingdom who is
strong enough would be forced to become
a devil host that would certainly make
all of those people stronger
individually and it would make the spade
kingdom as a whole much stronger but it
would also be an absolutely brutal act
of magical totalitarianism whatever it
is this plan must make some sort of
sense since xenon seems to be fully
committed to fighting for it and he
seems to think that this really is for
the greater good of the entire spade
kingdom definitely let me know what you
guys think the ultimate plan is turn all
spade kingdom citizens into zombies into
devils or into something else all
together and now let's get back to the
big fight xenon is confident that juno
can't beat him now that he managed to
destroy his stars without the stars juno
cannot teleport in order to avoid
xenon's spatial magic attacks and he has
no reliable way of destroying xenon's
devil heart xenon believes that this
fight is over but to be fair he has said
this several times before and it didn't
exactly work out the way he thought it
would in the end as the situation
becomes increasingly desperate for juno
and as he finds himself at his limit
even with two magic attributes at his
disposal he decides it's time to use his
trump card saint stage occurs when the
resonance between an elemental spirit
and their host is close to 100 percent
because he kept on fighting even on the
verge of death yuno has finally managed
to unlock this state and as we saw with
noel and on dean saint stage allows the
user to destroy devils even without
possessing arcane stage magic just as
xenon prepares to deliver the final blow
to yuno yuno uses saint spirit of zephyr
to seemingly cut through xenon's devil
heart and presumably kill him although
that is exactly when the chapter ends
and we don't get to see the aftermath of
juno's attack since this is black clover
we can't say that xenon is actually dead
yet but it definitely appears that his
devil's heart has been sliced by saint
spirit of zephyr we know that this fight
has to be over sometime and this really
could be the end for xenon but i'll wait
to see the next chapter before making
any sweeping conclusions
that said i can definitely understand
how yuno and silf could achieve near 100
residents in order to activate saint
stage they've known each other for a
long time and they are very close but
the fact that noel and nandin were able
to unlock saint stage despite barely
knowing each other is kind of crazy when
you think about it what do you guys
think is xenon really dead or if not
dead is he at least defeated for good if
this is the end for xenon then all three
members of the dark triad have been
defeated and so the story will have to
shift to the next villain and that
villain may be the final villain of the
entire story could this new villain be
morris or the cliff of devils or is this
villain the mysterious fourth so gratis
sibling in terms of the fourth sibling
in particular the fact that his face was
deliberately concealed is definitely a
big deal and as i mentioned earlier the
craziest theory out there that i've
heard about his identity is that he
could actually be wizard king julius
nomacrono himself according to this
theory julius's time magic is not his
original magic his time magic actually
comes from the time magic devil one of
the three strongest devils along with
the spatial magic and gravity magic
devils since none of the three dark
triad members are hosting the time magic
devil its host must be the fourth
sibling and if this fourth sibling
really were to secretly become the
wizard king in a rival kingdom that
would definitely help advance his plans
oh and let's be honest if the final
sagrada sibling really turned out to be
julius he would make a pretty insane
final villain there is a lot more to
this theory including stuff about julius
original magic actually being
transformation magic which is what
allowed him to create such a convincing
new identity i won't go into it too much
but another anime youtuber called broku
made an entire video on this theory if
you want to check it out i will link it
in the description it is a really
interesting concept for sure but i am
skeptical just because julius has so far
been portrayed as so moral and righteous
it would be absolutely shocking to me if
he turned out to be as nefarious as the
zogratis siblings but you never know so
i want to open the floor up to you guys
who do you think is the final zogradus
sibling is he someone that we already
know and could he even be julius himself
do you think that julius would make a
good final villain for the entire story
or are you hoping that someone else will
take that spot don't forget to leave
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this black clover video
and you want to see more in the future
just leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to anime opera or maybe you watch
our videos we just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror and of course a big thank you
to all of our anime uproar patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
guy is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones that rise above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa hinokamian water the toasted
chi corey mcgowan the spike 8227 kaido
might be a gyarados dylan isidor spidey
life tinel tungsten targus big buddhist
cody hebert and jeremy cummings finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red-haired ravens steelers
on hell crews very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia fat boy
games and jessica rabbit if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you